hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play cry of fear okay the last
time I left off I was lost I think yeah
probably still lost I don't know where
I'm going Wow where did that Oh bed guy
yeah here is startled they almost gave
me a heart attack
trying to do okay so basically I've got
this key
Ronald Street how I get to Ronald Street
is a mystery the stores broken that door
leads to nowhere and I don't want to go
through the subway tunnels again so I'm
guessing I just go back the way I came
because I musta missed it or someone I
should shut up yeah
these maps and get to where I need to go
this is not then I'm just going to be
lost forever monsters all the way up
until this point but after that I do not
know there weren't any new monsters in
the subway I'm guessing that wherever I
need to go is in this Street area here
otherwise none of it makes sense why put
new monsters there
I'm gonna come back
second clock ticking okay wish I could
look at it ah here we go
that's perfect okay I need to go Ronald
Street which is you can get to it in
wasp it's Gardens
see we're here so if I go back a little
bit it's only a little bit back and then
I get up Ronal street yeah right there
so if I'm right here there you go
through subway
no not subway system to reach Hanson I
got through the subway I need to get to
Ronald Street now I'll get up okay so
this is the caddy corner to that then I
need to go back this way the Ronald Park
area
this is Markarian oh this is my pay on I
get a look at it again I don't have
photographic memory as a man inspector
what apps I'll get this at least I'm on
the right track
Oh
second Avenue okay that goes back to the
park language I'm guessing that what is
what that is don't wait oh yeah that
ducks in there oh if I wanted to go that
way
I have to get hard
I think
stop double-park
oh man I wish I had a map with me
they're not kind enough to give me in
that okay but either way I gotta go back
that's the same markup thank you
it may not be it may be because if you
remember they've been to parking Park
with the giant guys and then the park
with um the animal statues but still
lost oh man I don't know I still don't
have an objective screen I still don't
have a menu this all lost 100% lost I
know there were new monsters come out
this way but I don't even know why so
getting back to work last bit Gardens
that that's where I need to go right the
way there will be a map should lead me
in the right brick
how is it this oh damn it
hey Emmett come on aah
ohh high hopes for nothing oh well
cabone now get me to where I need to go
monster pop out at me scare me a bit
okay yeah here's the park okay
this is the park here's another map yes
I'm at wasp it Gardens
Ronald Street is just down that way okay
if I just go down Parkway okay I'm gonna
keep doing that
don't parkway oh damn it okay wasp it
Gardens through here oh sorry you're
still dead you'll be concerning when you
get back in
Gardens down this way somewhere maybe I
can get around I can't get around still
block the blocked off but I can't go
where I need to go
does it probably does this is the door
that I came in right oh dammit
where there was a door that I came in
through this park again so I could find
my way back again and go through because
that would lead me back to where the big
dudes were and maybe that's where I need
to go who's that other door shut the
door my damn it
which door was it come on now this door
then go okay
this door and then I should be back with
the big dudes hello hello big guy
Oh Nicky I'm sneaky you can't see me
stay over there maybe there were other
doors that were kind of locked up so
maybe if I go through one of them
phone here you don't see jack you know
he crap nope
dump dump you stay there scare that bro
stay there it's not a door
hey there big guy so he's so strong man
I know he found me
oh those carrots oh you can't do jack
get out here you big loser loser Oh
crazies hello crazy hang on get my gun
up what that reload stop back off buddy
someone said oh yeah you the bun someone
mentioned that okay hitting all the big
guys and crazy down drop like a rock
okay big fast or agile I think the other
door is gonna be boarded up as well fear
no not my fear Oh punchy punchy yeah
got you coming either closing in on me
I got Buri ah come on now hopefully this
doesn't just lead back to the other Park
which it does ah damn it
okay damn it okay there's got to be a
way back I saw I saw oh maybe this is
all wasp it Gardens hang on let me look
at that map again given that that's just
a walled of party other side applause
and then if I go I look at the map if I
if I just go through the door and I go
past the wall then the other side would
be where Ronald's right right then why
would they allow me to come back
father's over there the whole time I
would have been able to figure it out
yeah wasp it gardens obviously walled
off so if I go to waspey gardens and I
go the other side and go the right since
it was right over here wait what is that
tail trading station - Saxon Avenue yeah
no no no that's that's a previous winner
I'm not listening back okay so I'm
pretty sure I'm on the right track here
so I'm sad that I was off the track oh I
got my nightstick again I forgot we okay
I got three here and it's on the right
side so if I go right then I should find
Ronald's oh I don't think I oh you
startled me Oh what the heck should be
over there maybe maybe if I go back down
fine
look down here aha nor won't budge okay
never mind
aha moment gone
Ronald three why do you lewd me that's
just sad sad and pathetic is it this way
when I came down here this is where I
found the m16 and nothing else
because there was nothing else
Plus
do a ha
get back to grab my fuse I also need
another one what when did I need a fuse
are you kidding me that's what I needed
to do this whole time needed to go get
the fuse how was I supposed to know that
really okay I know how I can go back and
get my fuse that's why they put the
enemies there oh let me cut this tape
that's why they put all the enemies
there if I I've gone back to where I
need to go I just never neat I never
knew that I needed to get abused how
stupid is that man oh well that's fine
as long as it got a directive and I know
where I'm going I'm finding get back
through through the park and that's that
hi big guy come here I want to talk with
you alright what oh you feel ugly oh
yeah
no nice you anyway oh yeah good
does that other begun here
whatever it don't matter
now what would make those big guys
really scary is if they were really fast
so I need to go here using them and run
all the way back wow this is this
episode was a big waste of time
least I know where I need to go man
why would they give me my objective and
tell me what to do on a map that isn't
even mom in my direct field of view
that's easy to pass whatever he's done
headed in the right direction my mom
still wants to know where I am I'm lost
in Silent Hill so you can come get me
maybe swing back pick me up I don't have
a car so it me real nice oh all right
that's why they were all the enemies
here oh hello that's why everything was
here blocking my way it all makes sense
now
and it would have made more sense if I
had had an objective in the first place
but I did not so anyway enough of my
moping at least I'm gonna be able to get
this done so here here this is where I
shot crazy bang bang bang
sprinting juice
go down here and grab much
full space so since I don't need the
nightstick anymore because I now I have
melee on basically always got the fuse
alright yo let's go let's go back to the
bus bus I'm guessing the bus need to
fuse that makes sense
and then I move the bus out of the way
or something
either way the map said that I needed a
fuse there so I'm going there to get a
fuse to deliver the few who that's nice
music this nice and relaxing obviously I
couldn't gone through the subway again
because they just blocked it off that's
that making progress all that music is
almost soothing
yes okay don't put any more monsters in
my way I feel a lot more comfortable
going this way
nope no monsters
Oh
this way and I'm almost memorized the
entire layout
at the same point because I don't want
to risk a white screen of death grass or
anything going wrong and you having to
backtrack I want to get through this oh
yeah there we go oh I'm not going right
way oh come on I want to make some
progress in this episode I'm sorry
yeah okay let's see what I got not black
don't lag really really computer you're
gonna lag now oh I'm so close to the end
do it good sorry guys
sorry about the low frames per second
for some reason this just went to scoop
it on me get out of my way ask bag I
don't have time for you you gotta be
kidding me wow I sure am glad that I
touched that save point cuz I just
crashed Oh JA as a girl e10 the worst
part is on bumping up on the end of the
episode here and I haven't made any
progress at all and I'm going backwards
ah just aggravating the no end
this game doesn't point me in the right
direction it crashes all the time it
crashes a lot guy I mean I know it's a
mod but like this this is weird
and for one thing I have to I have to
jump through a bunch of loops anyway
just to make the game work alright
there's going to be a longer episode
because I want you guys to be able to
see something happen underneath is
wandering around and I ran out of bread
juice that is annoying just running out
and then you go slower than you ever did
the bus the boss the boost American guys
yeah use do you think all you spotted
hello big guy that's it for get on all
right
we're almost there and if this is wrong
if I needed to take the fuse somewhere
else I'm gonna rip my eyes out
alright guys I guess that'll be the end
of my let's play career this doesn't
work just play all against me sound
so I got the fuse now what the heck do I
do with the fuse how do I do now how do
I get back to grab my fuse I also need
another one
what no where do I go model hookers
that's a dope all this nominal this is
just you you want a fuse
I got a few all right I thought of it
scrappy I thought that I was on the
right track
apparently I'm not so sorry about this
guys I have to cut those up zoom here
but I promise that I'm actually going to
make progress I'm not going to come back
until I find out where this fuse goes
okay so thank you all so much for
watching and as always see you in the
next part
bye-bye